-Thanks to
a newly-developed technology,
we here at "Late Night"
now have the ability to record
the tiny voice that is inside
Donald Trump's head.
And you might be surprised
to know that,
like everyone's inner voice,
like all of our inner voices,
Donald Trump's is filled with
paralyzing fear and self-doubt.
So here it is, once again,
the tiny voice in the back
of Donald Trump's head.
♪♪♪♪
-Hey, Donald.
It's the tiny voice
in the back of your head.
And I want to remind you
that this is a medal ceremony,
but that medal is not for you.
So, whatever you do,
don't take that medal.
Oh, but you want
to take it so bad.
It's such a good medal.
You can't stop looking at it,
thinking about
how pretty it would look
around your fat neck.
But, hey, maybe someday
you'll get a medal.
You know what you'd
get a medal for?
Awkwardly swinging
your body side to side
while your dead arms hang limp
alongside your hulking mass.
♪♪♪♪